la maison d'Hitler va être transformée
en poste de police et ça fait polémique
je vous explique il s'agit de l'endroit
où il est Adolf Hitler en 1889 dans la
ville de branhao en Autriche la maison
inoccupé depuis 2011 est venu un lieu de
pèlerinage qui attire de nombreux
néonazis et touristes fascinés par le
nazisme même si claire n'y avait que
quelques mois pour éviter que cet
endroit ne devienne un lieu de culte
néonazi le gouvernement annoncé que la
maison natale d'Hitler va devenir un
poste de police et que les travaux
commenceront le 2 octobre leur coût est
estimé à 20 millions d'euros le tout
financé par l'État le but c'est de
remanier profondément l'architecture de
la bâtisse pour qu'elle ne soit plus
identifiables dès septembre un centre de
formation des agents droits humains sera
également installé dans l'eau l'option
de la démolition a finalement été exclu
car les historiens ont expliqué que
l'Autriche devaient se confronter à son
passé étant dossier qui fait polémique
depuis des années pour éviter de faire
cette maison lieu de mémoire est à même
mis en place une commission d'experts en
2016 et si ça mit autant de temps c'est
parce que l'État louait la maison depuis
1972 à la famille power propriétaire des
lieux depuis plus d'un siècle elle
héberge jusque-là un centre pour
handicapé et en 2011 les powers se sont
opposés à toute utilisation du bâtiment
le laissant inoccuper ce qu'il a
transformé en lieu de pèlerinage néonazi
en 2016 l'étape chinois pour exproprier
les powers et ce n'est qu'en 2019 que
l'Autriche est devenue la propriétaire
officielle de cette maison et avec ce
poste de police l'objectif est d'y
installer une institution publique
représentant l'antithèse du